hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the Superbad rapid and
let's tournament one of the tournaments
from the Grantchester it's a game from
Round four Anton Horrible's vs.
Vishwanathan Anand and sorry about my
videos yesterday I had a flight to
Germany and then I did reach Frankfurt
and then from Frankfurt to ANOVA my
flight got canceled I had to take the
train and then it was a well it was a
really long train ride and well when I
finally got here and then I had to go to
about Piermont which was my original
destination and now that I'm finally
here it took me really a long time to
get here basically so I was really tired
and I really didn't even feel like
unpacking my laptop yesterday so sorry
about that but now we are ready to
continue some nice action over the board
and this is one of the games I wanted to
show you we already mentioned that the
winner after day one was well not the
winner but the leader after day two was
Anton horrible so here is one of one of
the games he played against Vishwanathan
Anand so without further ado Corrib of
opens with d4 we had Knight to f6 by
Anand c4 e6 Knight to f3 and of course
d5 the Queens gambit the client is on
the board with Knight to c3 and Bishop
to b4 the error goes in defense Bishop
to g5 with h6 now a trade on f6 Bishop
captures Queen captures and Queen to a4
check we see this variation very very
often when we when we cover games edit
as it is played a lot on the highest
level
nice to see six blocking check also
guarding the bishop on before with III
preparing to develop the lights were
Bishop and Anand castles and here Bush
of the e2 is the main line but Cora both
prefers rook to d1 it is a move he
pretty much always placed in this
position we rook the d8 by Anand and now
core above the main move here is Bishop
to d3 he played it twice against most AC
and he played it in the fede grant Swiss
last month that game ended in a draw but
also in the European Championship where
he lost the game tomb of Seti and so the
trip to d3 is his main move but he
didn't have a lot of success with it so
here he switches the Queen to b3 it's
not a new move it's just
a different idea he prepared for this
game we have Queen back to e7 now
guarding the bishop here so the knight
can freely move also the Queen will
support the advancement of the pawn to
e5 with a three core Bob asks what you
want to do with the bishop so going back
to d6 isn't really all the great do to
c5 so here with not captures right away
but first D captures on c4 and in
between move Queen captures and only now
Bishop back to d6 so now you don't have
a pawn to c5 with Bishop to d3 finally
bike or above preparing maybe to castle
and now II five my honour and corabeth's
King is still in the center so it is a
principled decision to open up the
center core above of course isn't
interested with d5 pushing the knight
back Knight to be 8 and now for the
moment all of on ins pieces and the
Queen side are undeveloped and core
above takes this opportunity to advance
his pawn so instead of just castling
which is probably a normal thing to do
here he goes g4 and and also the Queen
from c4 nicely supports it so it's not
even a pawn sacrifice Knight to d7 by
Anand he wants to get the night over to
c5 this very nice outpost and now rook
to g1 hora both prepares to push the
pawn to g5 Bishop back sorry nice to see
five as planned
threatening the bishop here and Bishop
back to be one talking the bishop back
for later and now a very interesting one
sacrificed by Anand b5 we're okay if you
captured by the Queen maybe you can get
some Bishop to e6 in there but core
above captures with the night so for the
moment preparing to capture the bishop
on d6 and honor and advances the a5 now
the rook and the bishop can be developed
and the bishop most likely will come to
a6 but Cora buff says okay I'm not
really interested in anything happening
on the Queen side g5 Corbeau wants to
open up lines here and and of course is
not interested he pushes h5 and now core
above continues
attacking on the Kings side we have g6
and here it's this is one of those
positions where the ugliest move is the
correct one captures on g6 is is the
best thing to do here and you
just continue the game for example if
Anand were sort of Corvo were to capture
with the rook it's a bit bit too soon to
put the rook on g6 because here Anand
can just push push away the night and
also block the bishops defense to the
rook and after the knight moves now you
go king the Queen to f7 push the room
back and once the rule goes back now you
defend the e4 pawn once more you can get
the bishop now into the game the other
Luke enters the game and you defend so
this is one of those positions where the
ugliest move is is the correct move but
Allan plays f5 it's a much more soothing
move although there's a problem with
leaving this pawn on g6 for example if
the Queen ever found her way all the way
to h7 could be a problem for black even
though for the moment it seems like like
a hard hard thing to do
but Cora ball finds the way he plays
Knight to g5 not only is it an excellent
square for the knight but also the f7
and
East six scores are weak so you can play
Knight to have seven or east six
whatever you need and also you block the
Queen's defense of the h4 square so of
course you want to get your Queen over 2
over 2 H 4 so here Anand first place
Queen to f6 so what do you do here
Cordoba first place Knight to f7 you
could go for Queen to h4 right away but
horrible has a very concrete idea he
plays Knight to have seven now attacks
the rook and Anand here plays Bishop to
e6
Anand wants to give up the exchange
which would be which would be great for
him if if Knight captures rook captures
let's say and now in any move whatever a
wise place like say a four-year you
defend the night so you can move the
Queen then efore comes and now after and
unleashes well the bishop and the Queen
on these diagonals blacks pieces will be
much better than than whites rooks as
for a moment curve of the rooks will not
be doing anything but after better up to
a six of course horrible did not capture
the rook or above played a much better
move so feel free to pause the video and
try to figure out which is the move that
score above plate while I give you a
couple of seconds and also I hope
everything is alright with the audio
it's the first video I'm doing in the
new setup so hopeful
everything is alright so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations as you have been paying
attention it's important to grant the
Queen access to the h4 square so it's
rook to g5 it's just a beautiful move
preparing just Queen here Queen captures
and then Queen - Queen to h7 will be
deadly for but and of course doesn't
allow it he pushes efore and now
prevents the Queen from reaching the age
Foursquare also prepares the capture on
b2 but Cora Bob says this is not the
only way to reach the age for squared he
plays Queen e2 so now he wants to go to
h5 immediately while also guarding the
b2 point so you don't have any captures
with check maybe tricks
I don't play special captures on b5
there is no way to prevent the Queen
from reaching age 5 so he plays Bishop
capture some b5 hoping for core above
the capture and b5 but horrible is
merciless here he plays Queen captures
on h5 and now you can see that keep
allowing this pawn to stay alive on g6
was a big mistake the capture on g6 was
just a better move even though it really
it really looked ugly so on and started
running away with his king but we have
rook captures on f5 now attacking the
Queen we have Queen Katharine b2 now
Anand is almost ready - well he's ready
to meet the White King but the Queen
still guards de to D 2 square and also
which Corps above Horrible's move so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for korra book
it's it's a force mating 4 so you know
do try your best to find the easiest and
the fastest way to win so for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations on calculating the exact
sequence it's a mating 4 and for those
of you who just want to enjoy a show
it's nice thief 5
I discovered to check now the King has
to go somewhere if he goes back then
it's just Queen age seven mates so you
have to play a better defense its King
e7 rook f7 check King goes back and now
Queen to h8 check only move better
blocks and now Queen captures on f8 is
mate so of course
Anand did not play it out after Bishop
sorry after Queen captures after 95
check a discovered check it was in this
position unmoved 27 that vishwanath on
almond resigned the game and a wonderful
victory for Anton horrible who is after
three days of rapid after nine rounds
the sole leader of the tournament so we
can check it out there are two days of
blitz left so anything had happened but
it's important to note that for a rapid
you get two points for a win for blitz
you only get one point for a win but the
blitz blitz event is a double
round-robin so today they will be
playing nine rounds and nine runs
tomorrow so here here are the standings
after three days of rapid Anton [ __ ]
above twelve and a half out of twenty
very impressive as he is the one of the
lowest rated players I don't know if
he's the lowest rated player but it
seems that it seems he is he's 26 17 and
he's also a wild card so this is a very
nice accomplishment for him second
onigiri in Lebanon and then a shocker
I'm a media of with 10 and half
Vishwanathan Anand with 10 with nine and
a half
we have Fabian or Sergei and laQuan Liam
with nine vladislav our team here and in
last place currently Wesley so with
seven and a half that brawl with Magnus
in fish random probably took it solo and
Wesley so he's you know still getting
back to normal chess that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it really impressive
play bye-bye encore above I would like
to thank your gonna fund a Riviera
Richard thread well Frank Holmes Mahesh
Parra and crispy card for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see soon our
continuing the coverage of the at is
superb at rapid Amplatz tournament
checking up on the feeder Grand Prix and
I also might visit it either either
today or tomorrow or or maybe on Monday
still still don't know but I will keep
you informed so that's pretty much it so
thank you all I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your day